hi oh my goodness hello it's so good to
be here oh my gosh I've just been
traveling around so much and I'm just
happy to be back in LA it's stopped for
me to travel so much just because I'm a
mom yeah yeah I actually have two
amazing cats I'll tell ya a single mom
doing on my own you know it's tough
because they're at that age and I just
want to you know I want to tell them hey
I do it for you and they're like well
who are you tough to the Academy I don't
know what it's like to be a mom of a
human kid I don't have any kids that I
know of but they say that it's tough
they say that it's a heart hardest job
in the world being a mom right hardest
job in the world the easiest one to get
it's tough
a lot of my friends are becoming parents
now which i think is kind of cool
because it's like they made they got
together and made a new friend for me
that's a lot less judgmental you know
I'm a FEMINIST yeah no one's surprised I
do I do still take crap for it though
like people be like oh you're a feminist
does that mean you hate man I'm like no
I'm a FEMINIST that means men hate me no
such a weird idea to that like because
I'm a feminist I hate men like no like
I'm a feminist who happens to hate men
it's not related at all you know
and like I don't even hate all men right
like hashtag not all men like I just
what I hate is toxic masculinity right
like I don't like when men make me feel
unsafe or like when they talk over me or
when they like love Radiohead you know
like it's too much too much I need dude
feminists hear any male feminists all
right there you go great you crack the
code nice
I'm always telling guys like do you
believe in equality well then just say
you're a feminist right by the time I
figure out you don't know exactly what
it means we've already boned you know my
my last boyfriend was a feminist well he
was 25 so he's whatever I make him be he
loved that joke because I think I told
him to he was really he was really cute
he's a musician which I'm sorry
musicians are hot they are it's I just I
get really turned on by lending people
money I date younger guys a lot actually
we just we get along we agree on a lot
of things like should be hard stuff like
that
I think 25 was a little too young and I
remember the day I realized that that we
were just on different pages in the book
of life it's when a good friend of mine
was going through depression and she's
on medication now but she was feeling
suicidal and I was really freaked out
and my young boyfriend was trying to
comfort me and he was like God Alice I
just don't know why anybody would ever
want to kill themselves I was like oh
you'll see stick with it champ you know
keep sending out those demos
[Music]
No
I'm not the one it's perfect
alice wetterlund everybody
[Applause]
you